welcome everybody it is a very big
coronavirus news day I'm so glad that
you are with me because if you weren't
here I would just be yelling at the TV
and if I yell with people watching it's
considered normal in society we have two
sort of areas of news today
one is the reopening guidelines
they've already leaked in summary so we
already have them
so before Trump comes out we have the
benefit of being able to go through them
without the mango menace telling them to
us we'll just be able to read them
together and I'm going to get to that
momentarily we also have another set of
news which is that the consortium of
Governors that includes a lot of
Northeast states and West Coast states
prominently including New York State and
Andrew Cuomo seems to have announced
that they are extending social
distancing guidelines another 15 days to
May 15 now when I say seems New York has
announced it and we were told New York
would be acting in concert with a bunch
of other states so although the other
states haven't yet announced it it's
presumed that New York and all of the
other states in that consortium are
going to be doing it meaning we've got
another month from today which is
disappointing of course but pretty
clearly the right decision based on the
data we yet again have record numbers of
deaths coming for a two or three of the
last three days so that's the that's the
unfortunate news so so we're going to
get to a lot of these these different
things let me get myself adjusted here
you will notice that today everything's
starting an hour later it was announced
earlier that the 5:00 p.m. press
conference was moved to 6:00 p.m. the
press room is almost completely empty
right now so we'll see if it ends up
happening at 6:00 p.m. Eastern but in
either case it's okay because we now
have time to discuss what is going on
let me very quickly read a couple of
super chats that came in and then we'll
get to the the announcement today and
then we'll get back to your
participation Quincy Quincy Vidal says
but who do you think Biden's most likely
to pick as VP who would be your favorite
choice thanks for all you do everyone
smash like and subscribe I think the
most likely people are some combination
of Kamala Harris or Elizabeth Warren or
Gretchen Whitmer or Amy Klobuchar from
that group of four I probably prefer
Warren from that group of four and you
know we'll go ahead and see what happens
a Kevin Macomber says Tomi Lauren wants
to reopen America who cares she's
clueless Connor says you should stream a
mixer you know I'm streaming on four
places already I don't know maybe I
guess does a restream can you stream two
mixer from restream is the question I'd
be curious to know the answer to that I
don't know anything about mixer Ian D
says enjoying the new live stream layout
fancy thanks Ian Eamonn Minji says David
you should do a long in-depth interview
on the implications of a second Donald
from term him not being bound to
re-election is beyond horrific yeah do
you think Trump's unhinged now wait till
he doesn't have an election to win
bjbj chadwick says New Jersey schools
closed until at least 5:15 makes sense
and Phillip Neiman says how far do you
run on your afternoon runs depending on
how I'm feeling I'll do like a fast mile
and then do something else or I'll do a
couple miles slower like slower would be
like 10-minute miles faster would be
more like eight and a half minute miles
I don't really have an interest in
running much faster than that nor do I
have an interest in ever really running
more than than like a 5k at a time
Thomas Powell says it was a cryptic
crossword clue I thought you'd
appreciate it sales of toilet rolls to
self isolate seven letters I don't know
hoarding cacus Umbra says Trump is all
about branding that's why he wants his
name on the checks how do we brand his
inept response so he takes
responsibility he desperately wants to
avoid that's that the challenge between
now and and and November
Kevin Macomber says are you voting for
dementia Jo I've analyzed the two
options Joe Biden and Donald Trump and
Biden's better on every issue climate
taxes capital gains
you know everything but could we I've
given the whole list I don't even want
to do it right now cuz it's such a big
news day okay I'm going to now tell you
what Trump is going to announce today
because it has leaked and this will give
us an opportunity to look at it all
together very briefly I do want to say
thank you to Jodie Zeidler who just made
a pledge on patreon and been Newt so who
also made a pledge at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show okay what is donald
trump going to be announcing today here
it is and i've already reviewed it and
i'll tell you there is some good and
there is some not-so-good and i'll just
tell it to you like it is so let's dig
right into it donald trump unveiled new
guidelines on thursday meant to help
states loosen social distancing but told
governor's on an afternoon telephone
call it was their decision on when and
how to open states that's good news
clearly over the last 24 hours someone
got to trump and explained to him you
don't have the authority to tell
governor's what to do so Donald Trump
seems to have relented on that he seems
to be saying clearly he's not going to
tell them what to do you were going to
call your own shots Trump said on the
conversation I've gotten to know almost
all of you most of you have known and
some very well you are all very capable
people and you're going to be calling
your all shots that's good news that
hopefully we're getting away from a
clash on constitutional authority the
10th amendment federalism etc that's the
good news
ok the guidelines meant to speed Trump's
goal of restarting the country won't be
mandatory many governors have already
extended restrictions into may or banded
into regional collectives that will
determine their own reopening plans the
newest consortium was created in the
Midwest on Thursday by Democratic and
Republican governors this is great news
there's a lot of whacked out governors
but they all seem more competent than
Trump so I'm glad to see that we are
seeing governor's work together now here
we go into the details Trump wants to
provide a framework for how to reopen
despite concerns that testing capacity
is too small which it is in a document
provided to all 50 US governor's the
White House spelled out a three-phase
approach to easing restrictions that
depends on
specific case count and hospital
capacity thresholds this is good
anything met any metrics and data or
data that will be used is good the
benchmarks for the first phase include a
sustained decreasing cases over a 14 day
period and a return to pre-crisis
conditions in hospitals according to the
document that's brilliant
so let's take a look first at if you
look at the numbers in the United States
in total you would need a 14-day
reduction in cases now when they go up
and down I don't know if it means 14 it
has to be consecutive days if there's a
one day blip on day 8 are you going back
to 0 we don't know but that's a nice
metric because when we talk about the
peak the peak isn't one day the peak is
a plateau and as you can see we have
been bouncing around this same level for
new cases going back a full two weeks
and the peak is typically a three to
four week plateau in terms of deaths
this is explained because a bunch of
deaths were recategorize discs Ovid but
regardless yesterday we still had 2600
and today the US is already at 2000 of
course these are going to be
state-by-state numbers so New York seems
to be quite a ways past its peak whereas
other states clearly or not so that's
important number two states should have
the ability to quickly set up safe and
efficient screening and testing sites
quickly and independently supply
sufficient personal protective equipment
hugely important yesterday we looked in
detail and tomorrow on the broadcast
show I'm gonna look in even more detail
at the Morgan Stanley roadmap and the
roadmap talks about early infected
people could go back to work June 15 if
if we are testing a million people a day
for active infection and we have
widespread antibody testing to determine
who has recovered the testing has to be
a huge part of it I'm glad that it's
mentioned although there's not really
that many specific metrics here the
phased approach encourages individuals
to continue
washing hands consider using face
coverings in public employers should
enact social distancing temperature
checks testing and sanitation practices
in their workplaces in the first phase
the document suggests schools that are
currently closed remain so I think we
should forget about reopening schools
this semester there's just no point in
it it's too much moving around I don't
think there's any advantage to getting
back for what is in some places going to
be only a couple of weeks that's my view
employees who are able to telework
should keep doing it from home so the
point here is start to reopen some
retail facing businesses if you can
large venues including restaurants can
operate under strict social distancing
protocols gyms can open as long as they
maintain social distancing guidelines
that seems dicey I'm not going to lie a
bars should remain shuttered that seems
like the right decision the guidelines
still recommend minimizing non-essential
travel and indicate vulnerable
populations should remain sheltered in
place phases 2 & 3 gradually decrease
the recommended restrictions so this is
the framework this is the framework I
think the good news is Trump is waving
the white flag on he has the ultimate
authority he's saying governors have the
ultimate authority that's the
constitutionally accurate thing that's
the federal under federalism that's
accurate the better we avoid the the the
more able we are to avoid that fight the
better off everybody's going to be I
hope that today from the doctors and
hopefully we see dr. Fauci because he's
been missing for a couple of days since
Trump told us he had complete confidence
and foul Qi we haven't seen him I hope
voci is here today and that is a preview
of what we are expecting to happen today
if you're just joining us on Twitter
twitch YouTube and Facebook we are 10
minutes from today's White House
coronavirus press briefing during which
Donald Trump will lay out the guidelines
I just laid out for you because they
have leaked with regard to starting to
ease up on social distancing oh the
other thing is Trump this is a report I
got Trump was sort of teasing we might
even do some stuff before May first some
states may open before May 1st from what
I've read
Trump has concede
this can only say on May first is the
first day you can open if you've had 14
straight days of declining cases we'll
see if Donald Trump mentions that today
okay let me thank a whole bunch of
people niandra 33 and g-money rider as
well as the soulless wolf and alien P
have all subscribed on Twitch and I'm so
grateful for that twitch is a beautiful
perfect place to support the work that
we do I want to say thanks to Alan Jones
whose new patron number three today and
T who is new patron number four today
Zach Williams is new patron number five
I really appreciate your support as
folks are starting to file into the
press briefing room super chats are
coming in very very strongly let's see a
lien piece says in New York they are
digging mass graves in Michigan they
complain about grass seeds and hair
roots crazy world very much so
sorry where did we go I missed okay
there we go
Mohammed Pope says do you think it's
likely Joe Biden would Rick pic Cristen
cinema for VP she's young and
conservative I would be shocked I think
there's no chance of that the Hunt Club
podcast says do you think progressives
would support Biden if he chose Nina
Turner as VP I don't know I think
there's no chance of that
Madi i speedy says David the never Biden
movement is morally obtuse and
trivializes the existential dangers of
reelecting Trump it is not one of virtue
but resentment very strong words Emanuel
Ramirez Vera says Trump is more left on
trade war and criminal justice I don't
know I'm not so sure about that I'm not
sorry I think the devil is in the
details there Marika says do you think
Lindsey Graham could lose he could but
it's not likely
his opponent Jamie Harrison did better
in fundraising so far yeah we've been
covering that I think Susan Collins
could lose I think martha mcsalley could
lose Lindsey could but it's it's looking
less strong let me put it that way
pudding pop says [ __ ] [ __ ] lulu Huma
who
poopoo wagga wagga doo-doo gala gala
choo-choo
I hope that was worth 5 bucks Matt
Chavez says Warren for vice-president
would make that Simpsons episode likely
gnorga PAB says what kind of car do you
drive do you ever use the T I don't want
to identify my my driving around I have
a very very unique noticeable vehicle
and I don't want to be spotted in Boston
but yes pre coronavirus I take the
subway which we call the T here
frequently Kevin Macomber says which
Republican candidates will run after
Trump don't know too early to discuss in
my mind proton-proton jinx says if Trump
gets a second term will he still be able
to siphon off funds through campaign
contributions yes I think that he will
he seems to be an expert in that no
matter what he seems to be able to do
that a personal update if people are
asking we did have brown water here at
my house on Tuesday night delightful
brown water we had a total brown out
brown water coming out of the faucets
coming out of the shower and when I
called the Water and Sewer Commission
Commission there was screaming and it
was 10:30 at night I don't know that
much about public utilities but if you
call at 10:30 p.m. you don't want to
hear screaming when there's a brown
water coming out of your faucet so that
was not that was not a fun night
otherwise my urban garden is gonna get
going very soon I'm having large amounts
of soil delivered this weekend and I'll
be I'll be posting about it on my
Instagram at David Pakman otherwise
nothing to report because I'm
essentially not leaving my house in
practical it's not literally true but in
practical terms I'm not really going out
very much okay Allen Smith says David
have you heard what are your thoughts on
the idea that Trump runs his press
briefings late to pull viewers from
local night late-night local and nightly
news
it's conceivably possible I wouldn't put
anything by the guy Daniel Rivera says
what are your thoughts on tools these
chances for president you know I think
that tool C is finally starting to turn
the corner I think now that everybody's
gotten out of the way
Bernie's out of the way and you know
it's all happening I actually think that
she is about to consolidate a lot of
support and it's gonna be a really
incredible thing for her
okay Matias Germany says hey David what
nickname similar to sleepy Joe would you
give Trump I don't know I like the mango
Menace the tangent tangerine terror baby
authoritarian baby dictator Kaylin
Brooke says David have you seen Kyle
kolinsky and Mehdi Hasan back and forth
I don't see how people like Kyle cannot
vote Biden not only did I see it I was
involved in it
mehdi tweeted retweeted one of my posts
there Kyle responded to me it was a real
party on Twitter and it reminded me once
I got off of Twitter that Twitter is not
real life and almost nobody cared about
that argument that I was involved in it
was a sad moment but a good one too uh
it was a good it was a good moment of
clarity for me I guess I would say let
me say thanks to Roy Chitwood Roy
Chitwood is new patron number six today
at patreon.com slash David Pakman show
let me also say thanks to Zack attack
for subscribing on Twitch
okay Sean is thanks for the super chat
to Jean eglee's I believe eglee's is
Church in French is that right Sean King
says David should I have spaghetti or
pizza tonight
you should have pizza but it should be a
it should be a cauliflower crust see if
you can put that together bamberg Katie
says do you think turtle had McConnell
could lose sure yeah I mean I think the
most likely Republican senators to lose
that we should be targeting again are
Susan Collins Susan Collins and Martha
McSally Jeff Sessions will probably beat
doug jones in alabama
but maybe Lindsey could lose maybe
turtle could lose but there's some
there's some lower hanging fruit so to
speak unknown prodigy says Trump will
enter at exactly 621 Eastern yeah if you
want to if you want to super chat me the
time you believe Trump will start today
I'm glad to you know take over unders so
to speak our retro path act says World
Wrestling Entertainment was deemed
essential services and then
layoffs yeah I've never seen wrestling
shad durka wits says do you think there
will be a second stimulus check I'm I'm
leaning in that direction
I am absolutely leaning in that
direction yeah um okay oh boy what's
going on here
looks like our video has frozen hmm
oh did I fully lose my connection weird
oh it looks like I'm back did I go out
there did I did you guys did you lose me
all together it seems for a second like
I may have actually gone offline there
momentarily the connection browned out
okay I got you all right people they're
starting to come in here very very
exciting let me very briefly say this I
said Oh what is that guy is that a is
that a flag
oh no is that a second flag what is that
anytime you see a second flag it's a red
flag for me leaning it up against the
American flag I don't know that that's
allowed is that I have a symbol on his
back oh I see oh it's a stand okay Wow I
don't know what's going on there okay
I'm gonna mention this one time and then
I'm gonna shut my mouth yesterday this
worked really really well
we've been streaming every day we're
doing our clips we're doing the podcast
we're doing everything the best way
today to support all of this work is to
make a pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show six people already have and
it's a beautiful beautiful thing I will
thank every single one of you we
currently are where are we on patreon we
are at 1904 patrons there's nine
thousand people watching right now
across all of our platforms we could get
to 2,000 patrons like that but I'm not
even talking about 2,000 I'm only
talking about getting 19 more so
consider making a beautiful generous
pledge in the Solidarity of peace and
love at this time and I will thank
everybody you can pledge as little as a
dollar a month and there is no limit I
think the biggest pledge we we had on
Sunstream was a hundred bucks a month
although
we've got some we've got some bigger
ones in there as well but very very
exciting stuff and we will fill the bar
I hope with your help okay
other super chats that are coming in
black wave 54 says sue woo kovat kills
you know de vibes having trouble
discerning that she'll Craig mile says
David you're amazing and your news is
the only one that I trust well remember
I don't do news I just do opinion I just
I'm not doing we're not really breaking
news here
Adrian benningfield says hey David I had
an idea for the food that's rotting in
the fields couldn't farmers donate the
food to food banks for tax rebates
interesting idea
Shannon Bennis says wife sure your
button ups are untuk it's is that true I
only have to untuck it brand button ups
and I haven't warned them for a little
while so your wife is not wrong that I
have someone tuck it button ups they
were a sponsor for a little while Keaton
Klepper says you're kidding tools he
hasn't dropped I actually have no idea
what's going on with Tulsi babsy Cunha
says what'd I miss nothing yet other
than we already reviewed the full plan
that Donald Trump will be announcing
today there's an article on CNN
outlining exactly what the plan is
so we've already reviewed it so that
we'll be better able to just you know
take it all in once Donald Trump comes
up and starts starts blabbering kwb says
I'm not one of those crazy protesters
demanding reopening but I am starting to
one there has wonder has there been any
effort to quantify the loss of life
and/or quality of life due to the
economic shutdown I don't know a Trump
has tried to say more people will die
from staying home than from the virus if
we let her rip you know that I don't I
wouldn't call that a study per se study
would be a bit much pare tearin' says
hey David how could a green party
participate in the election since there
are no there are more than two parties
is new laws required no third parties
can participate but the problem is that
with first-past-the-post there's a huge
disincentive to support a third party
candidate even if you like them better
than a demo
madacorp Republican candidate because
you risk helping the candidate you most
disagree with so for third parties to
really be viable
we need campaign finance reform and
restructuring the first passed past the
post paradigm so to speak David Adams
says did you like my uncover cop meme I
apologize I don't know what you're
talking about
I truly have apologized Kevin Macomber
says Tucker was right Bernie is a lame
revolutionary oh boy shots fired a lot
of people turning on Bernie Felix my
argument is the revolution language was
the wrong language from the beginning
but what the hell do I know Felix Arroyo
says are you doing anything special at 1
million subs I don't know
we have nothing I want to do something
at a million subscribers let me see on
YouTube let me see where we are we're at
eight hundred and twenty seven thousand
okay so we've got a little bit of a ways
to go I I would love to do something
special at a million subscribers I don't
know what it would be I would take
requests
thanks to Toby Allen for the super chat
Zach Williams says second stimulus check
is needed but will take a while due to
trump inevitably wanting his name on the
next wave of checks as well not untrue
erielle says trump will come out at 6:31
we have one person who says 621 p.m.
Eastern erielle says 631 p.m. Eastern
Time Matthew Raza tele says David do you
believe very strongly that karl
Pilkington would be a great VP pick for
Biden by the way I paid for this using
my stimulus money I don't know enough
about karl Pilkington to be able to say
for sure thanks to Tony Thompson for
grabbing a youtube subscription Tanner
captain of glue says hey David do you
ever listen to Sean Carroll's podcast if
not highly recommend also you should
host another chess tournament yeah I
might do another chess tournament next
week and I I don't really listen to any
podcasts dr. Burks is here don't tell me
no foul Qi again unbelievable
alright let me quickly thank people
because we're about to
started here Gary Frank is new patron
number seven Michelle Sanderlin is new
patron number eight kamar pizzas new
patron number nine Cordelia biscuit
barrel is new patron number ten today
Cerreta Lamarr is new patron number
eleven nee andrás new patron number
twelve
number thirteen is barry mccockiner
thirteen barry mccockiner matt bean is
new patron number fourteen vince Steinke
is new patron number fifteen and I think
I got everybody oh I also want to thank
piano man for doubling their pledge on
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show thank you very much
appreciate that the bar will keep
filling even when Trump is speaking
because we can we can walk and chew gum
at the same time so to speak Oh Michael
betit is also number 17 today very much
appreciate so we've got dr. Burks we
have Fox News's John Roberts I forget
this guy's name
that's not Chad right that's is that dr.
Han I forget who that is this is dr.
Redfield and we are expecting big big
announcements and dr. Anthony foul he's
absence is extremely concerning to me
very very concerning to me in terms of
what's going on here as we are just
moments from Donald Trump starting the
presence of the video screens turned on
suggests we will see a propaganda video
once again here and that is very very
scary if you have just joined at the top
of the hour on Twitter's which YouTube
and Facebook rescheduled from 5:00 to
6:00 p.m. today
we are going to get the guidelines for
the reopening of States we've already
gotten a preview one of the parameters
will be a state must have 14 days of
successive declining cases as well as
returning to pre kovat hospital capacity
or utilization may be better said and
testing capacity I don't know if they're
putting any metrics on the testing
capacity a gyms will be able to open in
those states with social distancing
restaurants will be able to open with
social distancing bars will not be
allowed to open how do you distinguish
between how do you a bar and a
restaurant that has a bar inside it I
don't know there are folks saying that
foul Chi is in the room and that he
walked in first I didn't see that I
didn't see that what I did see is that
Chad Barrientos is new patron number 18
today thanks Chad very much appreciate
it
let's see here Matthew Gautier says this
is the only thing I'm buying from my
stimulus check since it's not even
enough to cover my bills better be
another one coming Liz Francis says the
toddler and chief will start at six
eleven yeah I don't think 631 or 621 are
going to be the right start times cuz
everybody else is already in the room
Tom Dick now says thank you for your
continued work from the UK much love
thanks Tom
Christian birdie ell says I already have
received my stimulus check via direct
deposit joke's on Trump that he wanted
his name on it pair T Ron says wow he
put the standard on the floor here is
Donald Trump we will go over to c-span
because we get a much more uh well I
guess I'll switch over momentarily our
nation is engaged a historic battle
against the invisible enemy to win this
fight we have undertaken the greatest
national mobilization since World War
two and that's exactly what it's been
we've marshaled every instrument of
American power and we've unleashed her
most potent weapon of all the courage of
the American people
these have been trying times a cruel
virus from a distant land has unfairly
claimed allows ins of precious American
lives to every citizen who has lost a
cherished loved one your pain is our
pain we mourn as one national family our
country has come together we draw a
solace from the faith that God has
received and the departed he has taken
the departed
confused by his to his eternal and
loving embrace they will never be
forgotten over the last weeks and months
millions of Americans have joined
together gather in a switching that God
has received and the departed he has
taken the departed into his eternal and
loving embrace they will never be
forgotten over the last weeks and months
millions of Americans have joined
together in a shared national sacrifice
to halt the spread of this horrible
disease the army built field hospitals
and sports arenas and convention centers
the Army Corps of Engineers is great
over twenty thousand beds in record time
the Navy sailed hospital ships to our
biggest cities life-saving supplies and
experimental medicines were rushed to
the frontlines as we launched a rapid
search for groundbreaking treatments and
vaccines we built the most advanced and
robust testing not anywhere in the world
and we've done more testing than any
country not per capita anywhere in the
world wrong we suspended dangerous
foreign travel we leveraged our
industrial base to produce vast
quantities of critical medical gear and
enacted a historic two trillion dollar
relief package through it all we have
seen the heroism of our doctors and
nurses like never before these are our
warriors the bravery of our truck
drivers such bravery booty suppliers
such incredible bravery and the
determination and drive of our citizens
through this unified national endeavor
we have made great progress you could
really say incredible progress our
experts and
this report that our strategy to slow
the spread has saved hundreds of
thousands of lives models predicted
between 1.5 million and 2.2 million
that's a few asking which no president
would of course ever do if there was no
mitigation it could have even been
higher than that and between 100,000 and
240,000 deaths with mitigation it's
looking like we will come far under even
these lowest numbers thanks to our
all-out military operation and the
extraordinary devotion of our people we
believe we will experience far fewer
deaths then even the optimistic
projection but there is no such thing as
an optimistic projection on death one
person is too many our experts say the
curve has flattened and the peak in new
cases is behind us nationwide more than
850 counties or nearly 30% of our
country have reported no new cases in
the last seven days because of our early
and aggressive action we have avoided
the tragedy of health care rationing and
deadly shortfalls that have befallen
many other nations nations which
wherever possible we are helping in
America no person who was needed a
ventilator has been denied a ventilator
for making hundreds of thousands of
ventilators we've delivered thousands
and thousands of ventilators to the
states and actually it's been an
incredible operation we started with
very little and we ended with a lot the
United States has achieved a significant
lower mortality rate than almost all
other countries based on the latest data
our team of experts
now agrees that we can begin the next
front in our war which we are calling
opening up America again
and that's what we're doing we're
opening up our country and we have to do
that America wants to be open and
Americans want to be open as I have said
for some time now a national shutdown is
not a sustainable long term solution to
preserve the health of our citizens we
must also preserve the health and
functioning of our economy over the long
haul
you can't do one without the other
cannot be done to keep vital supply
chains earning chains these chains have
to be taken care of so delicately
they're delicate the balance is delicate
we want to deliver food and medical
supply elements we must have a working
economy and we want to get it back very
very quickly and that's what's going to
happen I believe it will boom a
prolonged lockdown combined with a
forced economic depression would afflict
an immense and wide-ranging toll on
public health this includes a sharp rise
in drug abuse alcohol abuse suicide
heart disease and many other dimensions
of physical and mental well-being we
have no data on this moreover many
patients have put needed medical care on
hold creating entirely new hazards for
Public Health our country has suffered
the world has suffered one hundred and
eighty four other countries have
suffered
therefore my administration is issuing
new federal guidelines that will allow
governor's to take a phased and
deliberate approach here we go to
reopening their individual states I've
dealt with them now a long time and
we've had a great relationship
Democrat Republican to relay
ship has been good this strategy is
based on hard verifiable data I want to
thank dr. Burks for her incredible
leadership in crafting these guidelines
in consultation with scientists
what about experts and medical
professionals across government dr.
Burks will explain the guidelines in
more detail in a few moments and dr.
pouchy has been absolutely terrific
we've all worked together
whereís and we've worked together well
they are interested in the health of our
country and we're all interested in the
viability and making us truly great
again we took the greatest economy in
the history of the world and we closed
it in order to win this war and we're in
the process of winning it now our
approach outlines three phases in
restoring our economic life we are not
opening all at once but one careful step
at a time and some states will be able
to open up sooner than others some
states are not in the kind of trouble
that others are in now that we have
passed the peak in new cases we're
starting our life again we're starting
rejuvenation of our economy again in a
safe and structured and very responsible
fashion our strategy will continue to
protect senior citizens and other
vulnerable populations while allowing
military sorry
and other groups of incredibly talented
people to go about their real business
and the business that's supposed to be
hard at work at doing and nobody does it
better our military is the greatest
anywhere in the world and we're so
thankful for what Nellie the consortium
of states that are not going to open for
a while are about 40% of the population
at off-the-top done the ground allow
instead of a blanket shutdown we will
pursue a focus on sheltering the highest
risk individuals so important we're
establishing clear scientific metric and
benchmarks on testing new case growth
and hospital capacity that must be met
before advancing to each phase and
that's each phase specifically in the
reopening of our country this is a
gradual process as the caseload in a
state continues to go down restrictions
can continue to be eased and come off
let's get to throughout the process
citizens will continue to be called upon
to use all of their weapons in this war
vigorous hygiene teleworking when
possible staying at home if you feel
sick maintaining social distance
sanitizing commonly used surfaces and
being highly conscious of their
surroundings those are our weapons
interesting because he's going back to
the language of before we did the
shutdown's wash your hands keep your
distance and everything's going to be
fine
then we got an exponential growth
pandemic first circumstances of their
own states every state is very different
they're all beautiful we love them all
but they're very very different if they
need to remain close we will allow them
to do that and if they believe it is
time to reopen we will provide them the
freedom and guidance to accomplish that
task and very very quickly depending on
what they want to do we are also
encouraging States to work together to
harmonize their regional efforts we'll
have numerous cases where states have
worked and will be working very very
closely together as we reopen we know
that there will be continued hardships
and challenges ahead yes
our goal will be to quickly identify and
address any outbreaks and put them out
rapidly
if the virus returns in the fall as some
scientists think it may possibly these
guidelines will ensure that our country
is up and running so that we can
likewise put it out quickly
dr. Trump at the heart of our strategy
is the vital role of medical research
especially for therapies that will
significantly improve outcomes for
high-risk patients and reduce the need
for urgent care this will be
tremendously valuable in allowing life
to eventually return to normal at least
35 clinical trials are already underway
including antiviral therapies immune
therapies and blood therapies in the
form of convalescent plasma you've all
heard about some of these events and
some of these therapies they've come a
long way events what's been done in the
last four weeks is incredible we will
also continue to expand our testing
capacity we have now completed more than
3.5 million tests by far the most
anywhere in the world areas of our
country that have been hotspots have
done much more testing on a per capita
basis then South Korea we've done more
than South Korea and South Korea has
done a good job but we've done more we
will continue to work with governor's to
advise them on how to conduct both
surveillance and diagnostic testing we
have now distributed over 600,000 Abott
ID now point-of-care diagnostic tests
these are tests that are done on-site
and within five minutes you know the
answer positive or negative in recent
days we have seen a dramatic increase in
the number of tests performed by
hospitals and academic institutions with
more than 120 thousand tests recently
reported in a single day far more than
any kind
tree in the world has ever been able to
do and our numbers are actually going up
as these new and better testing
solutions come online we're seeing this
additional capacity reflected in the
numbers for this reason the number of
tests processed in commercial
laboratories has dropped from
approximately 100,000 to roughly 75
thousand tests quick interjection we
need to be testing at least a million a
day to even be able to send early
infected people back to work and ideally
we would get 222 million tests a day
which seems like a fantasy at this point
and states feel free to use that
capacity some in the media falsely
reported this as a bad thing when in
fact it is a great thing because it
indicates that the states are moving to
faster more local testing solutions
including on-the-spot tests so this drop
in the utilization of commercial
laboratories is an affirmation that
testing which is at an all-time high is
growing at a historic rate in other
words the laboratories are great but now
we have forms of testing that are much
quicker much better and we don't have to
use the laboratories but they're there
and they have a great capacity to do the
work as dr. Burks has been advising our
governors for weeks we continue to have
an excess testing capacity of 1 million
tests per week available for use and our
capabilities are growing every single
day especially with the new tests that
are coming onto the market rapidly
exciting new product as we begin a
science-based reopening we must be extra
vigilant in blocking the foreign entry
of the virus from abroad
border control travel restrictions and
other limitations on entry are more
important than ever to keep the virus in
check and allow Americans to get back to
work the sacrifices our citizens have
made and this time of crisis will be
remembered
studied honored and praised for
generations to come
we're really all working together
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
we're all working together this is not
about parties this is about our country
right now the American people are ready
to rise to the occasion once again they
are ready to show the world once more
that Americans can defeat any challenger
together we will rebuild this land that
we love we will reclaim the Magnificent
destiny that we share and we will carry
our nation forward to new heights of
greatness and glory I would now like to
ask Vice President Michael snow and dr.
Burks to further explain the new
guidelines I want to thank just
Burroughs dr. Burks I want to thank dr.
pouchy and I want to thank really
especially a man who has he can barely
see devoting all 44 hours a day this is
where his task force and done such an
incredible job are a great vice
president Mike Pence please Mike oh
there is pouchy okay go right for us
Thank You mr. president the members of
the White House coronavirus Task Force
today joined the president to meet with
bipartisan group of members of the house
and of the Senate to get their counsel
on the development of what the president
unveiled to America's governors this
afternoon the new guidelines for opening
up America again are a product of the
best science and the best common sense
that the president has marshaled on this
team and from a broad range of advisors
from all across the nation
normally I mute pens I won't today
because he may give us some of the
guidelines coronavirus task force early
on he made it clear that that we have no
higher priority than the health and
safety of the American people president
launched a whole of govern
approach and while we stand here on this
day with more than 640,000 Americans
having contracted to coronavirus and our
hearts go out to the families of the
more than 31,000 Americans who lost
their lives and and those who continue
to struggle with serious consequences of
the coronavirus the truth is that
because of the decisive action that our
president took early on suspending
travel from China and thereafter from
dis portions of Europe and South Korea
screening passengers because of the
strong actions in partnership with every
governor across couldn't he skip this
part instead and say please insert my
daily brown-nosing
into the record and just we move on
because this is such a waste of time
those are the cooperation of the
American people and God's grace God boy
we are slowing the spread we are
flattening the curve we have preserved
the capacity of our health care system
and we've protected the most vulnerable
in a word because of the actions of of
this president this administration
governors at every level or health care
workers and our fellow Americans we save
lives and every American should be
comforted by that right and we can see
it in the numbers in the charts that
I'll present today oh these three maps
track influenza-like illness influence
which in this instance is mostly
coronavirus across America the first map
reflects the total number of cases on
the week ending March the 28th the next
map reflects our data about the total
number of cases on the week ending April
4th how is Florida and we stand here
today with the final map reflecting the
total number of cases across America as
of April the 11th but these trends
underway President got past the White
House coronavirus task force to develop
new guidelines for opening up America
again this guy
were presented today first to our
nation's governors and it is our
intention at the president's direction
to provide these guidelines to assist
governors and state health officials in
evaluating the most responsible manner
this is to reopen the economies of their
states at a time and manner of their
choosing the guidelines as Americans who
are looking on will note begin with what
is the best criteria that our experts
have developed and taken downward
trajectory in cases over a 14 day period
of time
ensuring that states have proper
capacity in their health care facilities
the second set of proposals includes a
description of recommendations for state
preparedness and let me say to the
American people what President Trump
made clear to our governor's today if
our administration will continue to work
day in and day out through our task
force through FEMA to ensure that our
states have not only the medical
supplies but that we continue to rapidly
expand testing across the nation the
president reflected on the progress we
made on testing but a few statistics for
that as well which I hope are an
encouragement to the American people on
March 11th we had performed a total of
twenty 3588 tests oh my god because of
the public-private partnership that
President Trump initiated with
commercial labs across the country that
number was eighty three thousand five
hundred by March 18th and as the
president just said that number is 3.5
million today it is our expectation that
we will have tested more than 5 million
needs state per-capita guidelines states
should be able to test X number a day
relative to the number of cases they've
had I mean this is not these are not
guidelines
Boeing partnership with our States and
we want our health care workers and
people all across the country to know of
our commitment to that finally the
president directed us to propose a
phased approach to reopening to
reopening our
it is based on up-to-date data and
readiness and will continue to provide
the very best data to our States the or
key on their health officials the focus
is on the mitigation of any risk of
resurgence or the emergence of the
corona virus in states where it's not
yet emerged does this sound like a plan
to anyone maybe Burks will give us the
plan lines on the most vulnerable and
it's we made this very clear to the
governor's today these new guidelines
for opening up America again can be
implemented on a statewide basis or on a
county-by-county basis with that I'm
happy to turn it over to dr. deborah
birx and if I may mr. president I'd like
to also extend my admiration and
appreciation to dr. Burks dr. Fauci and
every member of our team I get soaked
around the clock we had record these
recommendations for opening up America I
know every American is grateful for your
leadership and for theirs Thank You mr.
president mr. vice president we're gonna
go through these quickly cuz I know you
have them and many of you have already
spoken to them on television next slide
please
this is a very important slide it talks
about the gatekeeping on the gatekeeping
criteria to moving into phase one it's
very much related to what you just saw
about influenza like illness and the
United States has been tracking
influenza like illness is through the
Centers of the disease control for years
both the state and public health
officials are used to watching this
County health officials are used to
watching it and frankly every family
around the United States knows how to
access this on the CDC website in order
to get updated F to date information to
the communities it also looks at a
cinder ohmic emergency room type visits
again housed at the CDC and really is
our surveillance program that can be
utilized for a lot of different
illnesses but in this case will be
utilized for respiratory diseases in
addition we are tracking the number of
cases and it must have a downward
trajectory for 14 days as well
the influenza-like illness and the
syndromic illnesses and a downward
trajectory in the number of positive
tests with persistence of high levels of
testing for the hospital's its interests
to ensure that we can treat all patients
without resorting to any crisis care and
ensuring that there's a robust testing
program in place for at-risk health care
workers including frontlines
you've never responders with the
emerging antibody tests next slide just
to show you what this looks like so what
the CDC did for me under the direction
of Bob Redfield was to chart what would
the syndromic
illnesses were reporting throughout the
early part of March and you can see in
New Orleans respiratory diseases we're
starting to be seen in the emergency
room that is the red line the cases are
shown in the dark blue line the gray
Mountain is testing and underneath that
is the Blue Mountain of positives and
you can see that the early alert was
present from the emergency room about
early respiratory disease you can see it
predated the cases so throughout the
summer when we do not have flu to
contaminate this picture we'll be able
to follow this cinder ohmic pattern city
by city county by county community by
community safe ice this is too
complicated for Trump and many of
audition the CDC has the influenza like
illness net distributed throughout the
United States very useful in the
wintertime that first peak is influenza
B in the red that's this season I showed
you all the seasons here so you could
see the seasons as they are displayed
the first peak is influenza B second
peak in the winds influenza A and then
you can see the corona virus and you can
see its decline and it's declining
towards baseline this will allow us
against it a real problem with this is
these numbers are often very delayed and
they're updated later we know what the
initial oh boy this is real trouble guys
localities that I described next slide
Oh God so hopefully you see that we've
brought CDC and their amazing talent of
individuals at the Center for Disease
Control and Prevention and with all of
their abilities to this response and
also to the surveillance that we need in
this response but I want to call your
attention to the third bullet on this
graphic so we're tracking those two
pieces that I described for the third
bullet is about setting up Sentinel
surveillance sites to be able to
distinguish and find asymptomatic
individuals individuals that you have
heard about that may be either pre
symptomatic or asymptomatic throughout
their entire disease course we want to
be able to find them in communities of
particular vulnerability so we'll be
doing sentinel surveillance throughout
nursing homes throughout inner-city
federal clinics throughout indigenous
populations to really be able to find
early alerts of asymptomatic individuals
in the community and both for the sender
ohmic cases that are tested the flu
influenza-like cases and the
asymptomatic cases doing contact tracing
again with support from the Centers for
Disease Control we can't do it without
each state and local government in
addition we want to make sure that all
the healthcare facilities have adequate
protective personal protective devices
and the equipment to handle the surge
and to ensure the ICUs
can handle increased capacity we want
every state to have a plan for the
health and safety of its workers in
critical industries and to protect the
health and Safety's of those living in
high-risk facilities including senior
care facilities as we discussed with
Sentinel surveillance but also
additional surveillance when we talked
with all of the states that had not had
a major Metro outbreak their sentinels
surveillances picked up always the first
cases in nursing homes and so this is a
very much a big focus of the plan moving
forward I won't go into the rest of the
details on this slide but there's quite
a bit of details on the expectations of
every state and local government next
slide you'll recognize this slide it's a
next slide please is this feeling like a
plan to anybody you'll recognize this
slide it's what we've been talking about
in the 15 and 30 days to prevent the
spread it's continuing those in critical
hand-washing or sanitize there is yeah
these are the guidelines that led to a
total shutdown affecting surfaces using
face covering while in public following
state local guidelines and critically
staying home if you are sick I know a
lot of people go to the workplace when
they are feeling ill you know when
you're feeling ill it won't get better
by going to work so we're asking again
for people to stay home when they're
sick next slide is for employers to
ensure that there can be social
distancing and a protective equipment
their temperature checks use of
disinfectant and high-traffic areas
including break rooms and assuring that
we don't do I said there's no
non-essential business travel and then
monitoring for any symptomatic
individuals in the workplace and again
what you all become ill at work to
immediately to go home even having
business travel on there is a bad bad
idea
like even having it on the on the
PowerPoint I'm gonna go through the
phases very quickly but you have the
details phase one again you have to go
through those gating criterias related
to 14 days of decreasing evidence of
illness and decreasing testing despite
adequate testing so phase one begins
with all vulnerable individuals
including those with comorbidities
continuing to shelter in place
ensuring that those that first go out
into the public are not those that are
most vulnerable to bad outcomes in this
disease and then ensuring that we
continue to do six feet maximum physical
distancing in public spaces continuing
to avoid large gatherings and all
non-essential travel for the employers
next slide again if a vulnerable
population needs to return to work and
cannot be teller working there should be
special accommodations for all
vulnerable populations as well as
options for teleworking we believe every
employee should encourage work return in
phases from 20% or 25%
40% to 50% and again minimize all
non-essential travel phase 1 continued
next slide if the schools are already
closed they should remain closed correct
all visits to senior living facilities
and hospitals should be continue to be
prohibited large venues including
sit-down dining can only be operated
under strict physical distancing
protocols and maintaining those six feet
gyms could open if they had again could
here to strict physical distancing and
elective surgeries can resume on an
outpatient basis
phase 2 next slide next slide again you
have to go through the criteria again of
a continuation of another 14-day decline
among those criterias that were in the
gating again we're asking for all
vulnerable individuals shelter in place
we did not put a timeline on any of the
phases we want the governor's with the
data that they have community by
community to be setting up those
timelines well again we're asking for
the public to continue to maximize
physical distance however we increased
social settings to be able to now have
50 individuals once you're not essential
travel but assume next slide this is for
the employers we still would like to
include encourage telework and the
common common area should remain closed
or be physically distance all
non-essential travel for employees can
can resume and then again special
accommodations for vulnerable next slide
this should be a relief to many of
households that have small children
schools daycares and camps can reopen in
Phase two visits the Senior Living
facilities however should remain in
hospitals prohibited large venues can
operate but slowly under moderate
physical distancing and elective
surgeries can resume on an outpatient
and inpatient basis Phase three and so
phase three I won't go through in detail
was is essentially returning to our new
normal with all of the what we talked
about through
phases continuing the good hygiene
practices continuing their respect for
spaces between individuals because we
know that we still have an issue with
asymptomatic spread I do believe with
this plan that we're both confronting
the issue of finding symptomatic
individuals through our networks with
early alert as well as those who come
and present to different hospitals an
emergency room with testing and contact
tracing but critically have put in place
what we believe is a safety net through
asymptomatic sentinel surveillance that
is centered around our most vulnerable
groups between nursing homes and native
are a Native American people and
indigenous populations and our inner
city groups that we know maybe in
multi-generational households and have
unique risk I'll stop there mr.
president thank you very much mr.
president mr. vice president
so as you've seen just now from the
detailed presentation from dr. Burks
this is a rather robust program for
re-entering into normality there's a lot
of details here and I know it'll take a
little bit time to digest them all so
what I thought would be good since I
really want to be briefed to allow time
for questions is to kind of take us back
to the discussions that we've had here
before and why this is a natural
evolution from what we had said before
you might recall that on a few occasions
when I was up here before you I told you
that when we get to the point we were
going to take those steps towards trying
to get back to some form of normality
that it would not be a light switch that
you could turn on and off I meant that
in two different components the first of
all that we are a very large country and
we have different dynamics in the
country we have areas of the country
that have gone through a terrible ordeal
and others that fortunately have gone
and gotten gotten through this rather
lightly
so that's the first thing the second
thing is that light switch on and off is
the exact opposite of what you see here
which is a gradual relation with the
first thing and the only thing in mind
as the health people here my colleagues
who are either physicians scientists or
public health issues the predominant and
completely driving element that we put
into this was the safety and the health
of the American public and I know there
are a lot of other considerations that
go into opening considerations that
you've heard of right from this podium
but the dominating drive of this was to
make sure that this is done in the
safest way possible so let me just make
a couple of comments to just reiterate
more from a broader standpoint the
things that dr. Burks did so well in in
a very granular detail first of all in
order to even consider getting into the
phasing you have to pass a hurdle and
that's the hurdle that we refer to as
gating in now when you think about it
and look at the map of the country and
look at the differences in different
parts of the country you will see that
there are some regions states locations
that are going to be almost already into
some of that gating and will have
already fulfilled some of those criteria
others because of the dynamics of the
outbreak in the area will take longer to
be able to do that but you don't get to
phase one until you get through the
gating and then in order to make sure
that safety and health is the dominant
issue the design of the phases were just
that you go into phase one if you get no
rebound and you satisfy the gating but
yet again a second time then you go to
Phase two if you have no rebound and you
satisfy the gating criteria for a third
time you go into Phase three so there
are multiple checkpoints of safety there
so as I've said from this podium when we
were talking about the first 15 days of
the mitigation and then we extended it
another 30 days
I essentially pleaded with the American
public to say let us make sure we do the
best that we can to accomplish that and
in fact mitigation works you saw the
charts that the Vice President and that
dr. Burks put up it worked and what we
hope and I believe we will be successful
if we carefully do this again with the
attention to the safety and health of
the American public that we will be able
to it will be staggered not every state
not every region is going to do it at
the same time that's clearly obvious
because of the very dynamics of the
outbreak but we feel confident that
sooner or later we will get to the point
hopefully sooner with safety as the most
important thing to a point where we can
be get back to some form of normality
the one thing I liked about it that that
dr. Berg said so well is that no matter
what phase you're in there are certain
fundamental things that we've done that
are not like it was in September and
October you want to call it the new
normal you can call it whatever you want
but even if you are in phase 1 2 3 it's
not ok game over it's not it's gonna be
a way that we protect ourselves because
as we know and as I've said from this
podium it may very well be as we go the
cycle around that there'll be this virus
that wants to come back to us I think
we're gonna be able to handle that thank
you
so I assumed that there's an also a
phase 4 which is after a vaccine is
developed right and available to
everybody so question on phase 3 being
the new normal
are we during that phase gonna be able
to see things like packed arenas for
sporting events large crowds concerts
the answer is it is conceivable that we
will be able to do that I think there
will always have to be attention to
making sure that we don't do all that
packing in together I think we'll be
able to have sports events in that phase
where you actually have participants
there I'm not sure you're gonna be
twenty thousand in it's a problem
formally and evenly temporally with
everyone but when people get to that
phase paying attention to the fact that
if there is a rebound of any sort that
when you're in that phase you can
respond to that or you've put it back
and going the other way so the
flexibility is that there may be some
setbacks I mean let's face it this this
is uncharted water there may be some
setbacks that we may have to pull back a
little and then go forward but John the
direct answer to your question I do see
us getting more towards normal if you
take a look at the dating criteria as
that Lian these guidelines that are
there are at least a handful of states I
just looked at the trend lines Idaho
Wyoming Hawaii Montana they look like
they've already satisfied that bathing
criteria in your call with the governors
this afternoon did you hear back from
any states who said we're already there
we could start the process again from a
number of Governors that said they're in
very good shape I also heard not only
from the call but I heard from some of
the governor's previous and I think
you'll have some very good things to
report over the next few days about
States opening up and I think John
having to do with you call on on sports
depending on the area depending where
we're talking about it you're gonna have
large areas of our country where this
has not been or has been totally
eradicated you'll be able to have those
Lorena's now with everything being said
a lot of great work has been done on
vaccines but you have a testing process
therapeutics likewise we have a lot of
great things happening therapeutically
that will be a step further but in terms
of sports they'll probably start off I
as you know I spoke to the commissioners
yesterday almost I guess of every sport
and many of them are going to be
starting with out the fans so it'll be
made-for-television the good old days
made for television and it'll go that
way and then fans will start coming in
maybe they'll be separated by two seats
and then ultimately we want to have
packed arenas when the virus is gone
we're going to have packed arenas and
we're going to be back to enjoying
sports the way they're supposed to be
and the same thing can be said for
restaurants so at a certain point in
time when the virus is gone we're going
to be back to normal please mr.
president and the doctors can you
clarify then it's the 30-day period to
stop the spread those mitigation efforts
still in place or have they been
replaced by this new guidance well
they're going to be in place to a large
extent and it also depends on the
governor's what they want to do United
States if you look at Montana Wyoming
North Dakota that's a lot different than
New York it's a lot different than New
Jersey so it's going to be very
dependent on the governor and we're
recommending as you see in the charts
we're recommending certain things
they'll be in place dependent on what
the governor wants to do if we see
something wrong we will be expressing
ourselves very strongly
Thank You mr. president does this mean
the state such as Montana and Utah that
already meet that gating period will
they be able to go to phase one is early
as sane tomorrow if the governor
besides you're talking about those
states that are in great shape already
they will be able to go literally
tomorrow yes met all of the guidelines
if you go back you're going back 14 days
you're going back even a month and they
have the ones that I'm thinking about
the ones that I've already spoken to
governor's about they've met those
guidelines actually pretty long ago
what's your message to the protesters we
see we saw a lot of Michigan but in
other states that are saying that they
are refusing to comply with the stay at
home orders issued by governors and
local officials I mean isn't it
important for everybody to go along with
this as we go through these phases well
they've been going through it a long
time John and it's been a tough process
but there's death and there's problems
and staying at home too it's not just
isn't it wonderful to stay at home
they're having fear suffering that this
country wasn't built on that principle
it was built on not go exact opposite
principle Ashley and I watched in one
particular state where they were they
want to get back they want to get back
they were very strict sanctions that
were put on people that was sank
probably the most strict of all but the
attack me I just think the American
people have been incredible when you
look at John when you look at what
they've done when you look at what
they've been through when you look at
all of the death and all of the problems
and all of the sickness when you look at
what's happened I just think the
American people have been incredible
protestors to listen to local
authorities I think that listening I
think they listen to me they seem to be
good as that like respect this opinion
and my opinion is the same as just about
all of the governors they all want to
open nobody wants to say [ __ ] but they
want to open safely so do i but we have
large sections of the country right now
they can start thinking about no one
wants the safe there'll be some
litigation and they'll keep it going for
a period of time including masks by the
way in areas that you wouldn't even
think I asked a question today I said
why would they wear masks in Wyoming or
Tanna or North Dakota and that's if
somebody should come in from an area
that isn't so successful in terms of
what they have done so that will be a
governor's choice and will have no
problem with it
mr. president you spoke this afternoon
with your new congressional advisory
groups 32 bipartisan members of the
house 65 bipartisan members of the
Senate one of the big topics was the
fact that the Small Business Association
long pot of 350 million dollars right
it's hit the cap it's exhausted there's
nothing moving on the 250 billion
dollars to replenish it what did you
tell those bipartisan groups today about
getting to move on to get some more
money into the hands of small business
so just for the viewers watching this or
hearing you ask that question
exhausted is a good thing not a bad
thing it went quickly it is so popular
the banks have been incredible including
4,000 community banks 4,000 most people
didn't know you had that many banks
4,000 you didn't know what they want is
people want to keep this going and we're
doing it to keep the small businesses
open and to keep the workers paid and we
have 250 billion dollar request the
Democrats like it the Republicans love
it and to be honest I think it's kind of
something's going to be happening I hope
so because this is a very popular
program it was really executed
flawlessly the first day they changed an
application a little bit there was a but
when you look at what Bank of America
did and what Wells Fargo did and City
and a lot of the banks but when you ask
when you look at what all of the
community banks did it's been really
incredible well we're negotiating with
Democrats and they should frankly
approve it quickly this is a great thing
for us it's a great thing for small
business and for the workers and we're
having a hard time getting them to
approve it I think it's gonna happen it
should happen really unanimously but
they're trying to get things and we're
not too happy with what they're trying
to get place
first could you just say which states
specifically you guys think of hit the
gating requirements rather that say that
but you'll be seeing it very soon I mean
there'll be I'd rather have the governor
be able the governor's be able to
announce and they're very proud of it
they've worked hard some are in an area
that's less susceptible and some really
was done I think we can say through
talent they really worked very hard and
you know we have some states that got
too much credit for what they've done
frankly I could name you a couple of
those too and I know they'll name a
couple of them and we have others that
haven't been given credit that have done
a phenomenal job part of the guidance
seems to sort of shift to States and
companies the burden not just of
additional testing and surveillance but
also this sort of new normal in which
you know there's smaller crowds and
restaurants and bars and normal there's
not going to be a new normal where
somebody has been having for twenty five
years a hundred and fifty eight seats in
a restaurant and now he's got 30 or he's
got 60 because that wouldn't work that's
not normal no normal will be if he has
the hundred and fifty eight or sixty
eight seats and that's gonna happen and
it's gonna happen relatively quickly we
hope but that's our normal or normal is
if you have a hundred thousand people in
an Alabama football game or a hundred
and ten thousand to be exact we want a
hundred and ten thousand people that we
want every seat occupied normal is not
going to be where you have a game with
fifty thousand years to that point
I mean best-case scenario that happens
in the states are doing really well in a
month obviously for I think a lot of
other state that's gonna be longer than
that so my question is
what is the federal government going to
do to sort of help especially companies
but states and local governments in
those positions pay for what is now
going to be an even longer at standing
we're going to be watching over we're
going to see that everything is working
out smoothly we're in very strong
communication with the governor's we're
going to be helping with testing they're
going to be doing the testing it's got
to be a localized thing and it really
has been since I've been involved
because I came in and federal
government's supposed to do testing of
parking lots in the middle of a certain
state that's two thousand miles away
it's ridiculous but the testing has been
so incredible two things testing and
ventilators ventilators are really tough
they have very complex they're very
expensive
wasn't it they're you know very
sophisticated machines some are
unbelievably sophisticated well we built
you saw General Motors yesterday
thousands are being issued we have 11
companies building them we have not had
one complaint in the last week and half
which is surge time don't forget when
they were calling they were calling
because in two weeks and four weeks and
five weeks they're going to need
ventilation up because they need them
right now and we were right on our
counts and nobody that wanted a
ventilator didn't get a ventilator plus
we have additional if there is a surgeon
we hope this seems to think the federal
government only has a presence in
Washington DC you know there's all these
federal agencies that are in every state
should have had them and we're also
going to have a big stockpile in the
federal government and we'll be able to
help foreign countries countries that
need help because you have look you have
countries we'll never be able to build a
ventilator it's tough stuff we're
uniquely talented in the sense that we
can do things that nobody else can do
we'll get it right back to you Joe Peter
in the back
name the states that might be right
ready to go though can you give us some
more maybe the experts the dr. Burks and
doctor thought you'd give us some sense
of how many yesterday you said 29 states
were in good shape you think is maybe
not Peter I think 29 states are in that
ballgame not open not for opening but I
think they'll be able to open relatively
soon
I think the remainder are just getting
better look New York New Jersey or
having very tough times and they'll be
there they'll be there at some point but
they're not going to be one of the
earlier states they're gonna be later
obviously I just spoke with the governor
of New Jersey we just spoke with Mike
and a couple of folks so we had a great
talk with him Phil is a terrific guy
he's working very hard Democrat but we
get along he's working very very hard I
guess the fact that he's right next to
this big massive city where everybody's
very closely you know that together you
get New Jersey's been unbelievably hard
as hard as hard as anybody in the true
sense but they're doing a great job in
New Jersey that doesn't mean that
they're gonna be opening next week
that's not one that's going to be but we
have a lot of states that through
location through luck and also through a
lot of talent we have States through a
lot of talent are in a very good
position and they're getting ready to
open and over the next very short period
of time it's going to be up to the
governor's we're going to work with them
we're gonna help them but it's going to
be up to the governors I think they're
going to I think you're gonna see quite
a few states starting to open and I call
it a beautiful puzzle you have 50 pieces
all very different but when it's all
done it's a mosaic when it's all done
it's gonna be a I think a very beautiful
picture and very important is what dr.
Farhat she said it could be that
sometime in the fall there'll be some
flare-ups we're gonna be in a great
position with everything we've done and
everything we've learned this was
something that nobody ever saw before
such contagion and very very powerful
people don't realize because you we all
probably have friends I have a number of
people that were just great people who
were just decimated by what happened
somewhere
some were some are dead right now
they're dead they went into a hospital
one called me he said I tested positive
four days later he was dead
just the following day after he said
that he was unconscious so this is a
tough deal at the same time some people
got sniffles and they didn't even
realize they had a problem and they are
supposedly immune we're gonna find out
about that even that's a little bit soon
because we don't know how long the
immunity less but Peter some states are
in great shape and they're really in
great shape to open and I think you'll
have quite a few states opening soon and
they're gonna be very vigilant they're
gonna be very careful public health
experts have said that this would be
better done if there were comprehensive
surveillance testing which were
obviously not in position to do I wonder
if maybe dr. Burks and dr. Valle will do
it together
I just wanted it's why I wanted to put
up the syndromic and influenza-like
illness piece because what is key in
this is the early alerts and getting in
there before they even know they have a
problem and I think CDC has been
remarkable in building these platforms
dr. Redfield integrated them so they're
all on the same website if you look at
Co vid 19 to go into cases you can find
all of the data and the beauty of it is
the states are used to utilizing that
through flu season so the testing and
contract tracing and dr. Redfield will
be putting people in every single state
to make sure that CDC is standing beside
the state and local health officials to
make sure that all of those cases are
immediately identified in contact
tracing
funny how five minutes ago Trump says
hey you know we're the federal
government we're in DC like we can't
just do stuff all over the country
Bert's casually says yes CDC is putting
people in every state so we're gonna
have people everywhere Unity's that we
know are particularly vulnerable and
that hasn't been done in flu before and
I think that's gonna be the added
dividend that's really focused on who is
most vulnerable and how do we get the
fastest alert by generally screening
people without symptoms so people who
are just coming to the clinic
we'll be screened for Kovan 19 and we do
have enough testing capacity to do both
that surveillance piece as well as the
diagnostic piece and contact tracing you
know people have gotten confused about
that goes in the beginning when we were
focusing really on just mitigation and
really trying to keep Peaks down and and
trying to worry about ventilators and
and PPEs and things like that well now
would you get a little bit more grace
period you can start figuring out what
is the penetrance of this virus in
society what are we missing
in people who might be infected what is
the percentage of those people that are
out there that's gonna inform us greatly
for a number of things including the
level once we prove that antibody test
that you have is really protective and
we still don't know that yet we're going
to find that out we may get a good feel
of what the level of protection might be
in society but we don't know that yet so
it's gonna give us information as to
what the vulnerable areas are and I
think we need to respond somewhere else
there were those two types of things
antibody tests and tests for the
diagnosis of who has the disease one you
need for contact tracing the other you
want to need for finding outlets in
society we're gonna have both of those
much much better as we go in the next
weeks and months and by the time we get
into the fall I think we're gonna be in
pretty good shape as we see a hotspot
possibly developing maybe not but if we
see a hotspot developing we've learned a
lot we'll be able to suppress it
whack it we'll be able to do things that
they're gonna whack people weren't even
thinking about because nobody's ever
gone through this in 1917 they went
through something that was similar
probably not as contagious probably more
powerful in certain other ways but we
are going to be able to suppress it we
think and we're gonna watch it very
closely we're gonna we're gonna be able
to watch things very closely please
Thank You mr. president I think what's
really important is during this trip
bringing people back to work and our
economy back to work and uh what's gonna
go back is that we're gonna be very
aggressively focused on early case
recognition isolation and contact
tracing in the event that we just went
through unfortunately in as we started
we were very capable of doing that when
the initial cases all came from China
all the way through January all the way
through to the end of February we were
able to identify cases early the first
fourteen do the contacts do the contact
tracing over 800 contacts we identified
that two of those contacts were actually
infected we were able to isolate them we
were able to contain the outbreak we're
about to enter a new phase of this where
we're going back to containment and
mitigation is going to continue as dr.
Burks and others have said some of the
things that we've learned to do we're
going to continue but the the major
thrust of how we're going to control and
make sure that we continue to keep this
nation open is early case recognition
isolation and contact race and that's
the fundamentals of public health that's
what we're gonna do you see we have very
good surveillance systems that are gonna
help us as we see these cases
sporadically across the country we've
got to jump on them with early diagnosis
isolation and contact Tracy and that's
what CDC is going to continue to help
build that capacity in in the states
across this nation we discussed this
today with the Senators where the
senators we had the congressmen and
women there'll be some areas of our
country wide open plains wide open
spaces with not that many people
relatively speaking where you're not
going to have to do that senators were
saying there is no reason to do that in
certain states in certain areas where
you have the wide open in other cases we
will be doing that so we'll be following
it largely that also will be a function
of governor's they know their states so
largely that's going to be a function of
the governor's yes
you used to turn clear scientific
benchmarks on testing and the main
periscope that I think you guys are
talking about it IOL syndromic as well
as the surveillance and the sentinel
testing are you opening things up then
without doing I just wanna be clear are
you opening things up without doing
widespread testing is that because you
don't have the capacity or you don't
think it's necessary you have the
capacity but you know you have States
without any problem you have States with
few cases and those few cases have
healed you have states with very little
death relatively speaking as I said one
is too many but you have states with
very little and if we do have the
testing capacity we should be starting
to test tons and tons of people it's
different case than a New York or New
Jersey where they're going through
frankly they go through hell and if you
look at New York I'm looking at bed camp
because you have to look at bed cat and
it's really dropped we built the Javits
Center with 2900 beds not the question
and it was I mean they built it in four
days it was an incredible job the Army
Corps of Engineers it was not used very
much we sent the ship the hospital ship
in to New York Harbor and it was not
used that we went kovat and it still was
not used because the bed count has gone
way down way way down this is this is
not campaigning I want to make the
country better I don't care about
campaigning this is this is about making
our country better I think this team has
been incredible right whether it's Army
Corps of Engineers whether it's FEMA one
thing that happened on the call today
that I noticed more than anything is
Pete Gaynor so many governors said I
want to thank you Pete Gaynor called up
they had tornadoes in a big part of our
country this weekend this week and they
were all saying that he has been
unbelievable they called one after
another they were thanking us for that's
FEMA yes mr. president and they were
thanking us no I want to heal this
country this country is a war we've been
through what we have an invisible as
opposed to a visible enemy I think in
many ways the invisible enemy is much
more dangerous as much tougher skort in
the g7 today I went through a country
after country we were
we all get along great Angela Merkel and
Shinzo ABI Prime Minister of Japan and
all of them and their their countries
have been devastated by this their
economies have been devastated by this
184 countries all over the world and we
went through one after another and I was
angry because this should have been told
to us it should have been told to us
early it should have been told to us a
lot sooner people knew it was happening
and people didn't want to talk about it
I don't know why but we're gonna get to
the bottom of it but people should have
people so I'm not saying anything I'm
saying
people should have told us about this
they should have told the rest of the
world to when I looked at Germany
talking today when I looked at France
talking today the European Union was
there represented that represents a lot
of countries their economies have been
devastated but they're gonna build them
back but we're gonna build this economy
back bigger better stronger than ever
before you watch and we have stimulus
and we're gonna do things whether it's
infrastructure which we would like to be
able to do our roads our tunnels our
highways our bridges our bridges need
help you know a lot of you have reported
on our bridges a lot of bridges are in
bad shape they should have been fixed 25
years ago and they're still standing
they have to be fixed so hopefully we'll
get an infrastructure bill the good news
is the interest rate is close to zero
and zero interest is a good thing when
it comes to rebuilding your
infrastructure in your country back
please in the back mr. president
walk us through the calendar if you
would when it comes to Memorial Day or
even Pentecost in May you've got to July
4th Labor Day weekend and would you
anticipate of each of those means well I
don't like to anticipate because you
have a couple of states that are in
difficulty that have made a lot of
progress by the way and they're either
here or they're heading down but so I'm
not going to go in in terms of dates but
I think we're going very quickly now I
really believe I think we're going to
have a lot of states open relatively
soon we're beating the date I set a date
of May
first and you know here we are and I
think you're gonna have some nice
surprises over the next few days and
that'll be before and that's big stuff
some of those states are big they're big
stuff very important states and it's
gonna be added on and on and as we look
I don't want anyone coming back that
isn't in position to come back the last
thing we want is for let's say a New
York to come back too soon or a New
Jersey to come back too so we want them
to come back when they're ready but
they're really heading in a good
direction and I think it'll be much
faster than people think I think it'll
be quicker but it's got to be safe thank
you has the government model the
possibility what may happen how many
guests might occur if there is a
widespread resurgence if this just
doesn't doesn't work so if we didn't do
what we did we were talking about up to
2.2 million deaths not the question so
that's five times almost what we lost in
the civil war okay everything happens
properly and if we continue to go the
way we're going now we will be
significantly lower than the lowest
number with mitigation so we'll be
significantly less and it's a lot people
don't spread by one is too many as I've
said one is too many but we'll be under
the number of 100,000 which was the
minimum number projected by the model
and I give I give everybody up here I
give all of the people that we've been
we this was a military operation with a
lot of private he doesn't answer
got it if you look at Roche they were
incredible look at Johnson and Johnson
now what they're doing they are humping
very far advanced animals yeah I think
therapeutically we have some of these
genius companies they're truly genius
companies I'm seeing I'm I'm meeting
with the people that run the companies
and scientists and I mean what they're
doing is incredible that's it's
incredible it's a beautiful thing to see
so I think we're very far advanced and I
think we're gonna be in great shape
yep
I know you don't want to mention
specific states but what about
Washington and California to have
guidance humane Washington State or
Washington here well that's going to be
up to them they're gonna have to make
that determination I mean the governor
of Washington was saying that he can't
find cotton because you know a swab is a
very easy thing to get and swab is
essentially it's a little bit more
sophisticated than a q-tip swab and you
got to be able to go out and find you
know the federal government shouldn't be
forced to go and do everything we've
done or the the ones that can't be done
like for instance the ventilators that
can't be done by anybody but a very
powerful very great manufacturing
country which is what we are and what
we're really getting to be and I have to
tell you some of these companies what
the job they've done and we're gonna
recognize them pretty soon the job
they've done in terms of getting out in
particular vendor list because
ventilators are so hard this so I say
and some people say oh it's not really
as complicated in California car
unrelated and you know what the price is
the same too it's a very expensive thing
for a sophisticated advented number
fourteen ninety-two president let me
toss this question up to you and to the
doctors as well truthfully for those
states that aren't ready to go to phase
one to get through these phases do we
have an idea of how many millions tens
of millions of tests they're going to
need beautiful for them to get through
these phases a bumper out there tests of
any sort yeah so I mean I you've heard
me talk about tests for a while from the
podium and I think what has happened
over the last several weeks is hospitals
and and clinics that could move to the
more point-of-care tests move to those
point-of-care tests and what it's left
is an amazing array of capacity that
exists in the country for at least a
million more tests per week so
we have a whole team working lab by lab
to see what it would take to turn on all
of those labs that are running the
pieces of equipment now so you see in
the system I just said to you there's a
million more tests per week that we have
tests sitting there and equipment
sitting there and now we have to really
deal with each single lab to really
figure out we need a million a day
minimum minimum and some models say more
but a million minimum a day through with
us and thanks to the lab directors they
really explain to us highly technical
difficulty to run some of these big
pieces of equipment because you have to
Alec lot the samples you have to
centrifuge you have to put them on the
machine takes a tech full-time at $50 a
test it wasn't enough to hire another
technician to run the machine full-time
so at $100 if money is so those are
kinds of changes we have to make bit by
bit by a hundred bucks but that alone
doubles our testing capacity per week so
we're committed to work with
laboratories to answer every one of
their issues with the state and local
governments and I think frankly every
conversation I have and the governor's
will say I need five thousand people
tested and I say well at the University
of X there are 67 hundred tests waiting
for you so it's more of making sure that
every governor and every public health
official knows exactly where every lab
is and where the tests are so we can
create with them a real understanding so
all these tests can be run so yes there
is twice the capacity right now just so
you understand we have tremendous cake
testing capacity you look at the labs
they're actually saying send us and the
reason it's gone down is because we have
so many other tests that frankly are
easier because you don't have to send
their own how many and now we have the
new saliva didn't get an animal test
that just came out yesterday which is
probably the easiest of them all when
you get right down to it and promising
where Rutgers was involved great school
great college great University
and they're using that so many people
are going to want to use that but they
don't have to use the labs anymore the
labs are great highly accurate very very
great companies but they're down they
have tremendous as as that goes down you
have additional capacity we have
tremendous testing capacity and to think
that a month and a half ago we had
virtually nothing I just want to
conclude we're opening up our great
country again it's going to be over a
period of time we're working with some
really great people people that have
become friends of mine and I'm I'm
including Democrat even governors that
have really done a good job
Republican governors most of whom I've
known that have done a really good job
they're all working together we're all
for that with few exceptions the
relationship has been outstanding and I
want to thank dr. dr. and Mike I want to
thank the director fantastic job we've
all done by the way head of the FDA he
has broken hurdles that years ago even
recently would have taken years he was
he got one thing done and one day that
would have taken two years for somebody
else
so I want to thank dr. Hahn of the FDA
we have incredible people that were
working with and we're going to bring
our country back and it's going to be
bigger and better and stronger than ever
before we have learned a lot we've
learned a lot about ourselves and I want
to thank everybody and most importantly
I want to thank the American people
thank you all very much
there it is Mike Pence daily having to
grab Trump's paperwork and take it with
him that is essentially his least
offensive role I mean ID when he talks
it's much worse than when he just takes
the papers so there we have that thank
you to everyone who has sent messages
and has joined me today Caledon and
gunthor both just got twitch Prime
subscriptions I do want to thank Kerry
Robinson Thompson who is patreon
pleasure number 26 today please consider
leaving a tip behind support the stream
by making a tiny tiny pledge as little
as you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show a few Super chats I do want
to address hear and feel free to hang
out anthony laws a go sends $100 super
chat and says I saw your response but I
couldn't see your name I don't know what
that means I can't send anything
anywhere because the chaos has passed my
compression but I know I'm work no I'm
working diligently to help everyone
everyone it's a slow uphill battle
against sanity holdout oh I don't know
what you're talking about Anthony but
you were being so generous by by sending
$100 super chat I really appreciate that
Athenian stranger says I'm a high school
teacher in Texas please don't open yeah
there is going to be a lot that it
simply has not been figured out yet
which we don't have answers to and we
won't until States start taking measures
we've got this consortium of states on
the East Coast and West Coast it looks
like they we I am in one of those states
and Massachusetts are delaying at least
another 15 days until mid-may I do fear
that this is going to be seen as a
signal tell me if you agree with this or
not I think a lot of people are going to
hear Trump say this their state won't
actually be saying it's time to do
anything but individuals will say you
know I'm getting a reading between the
lines Trump seems to be saying it's okay
to start doing some stuff and people are
just going to do it because
in many senses people are desperate
people are desperate and that is my fear
of what we are going to see as a result
of what Donald Trump has said despite
the reality that the guidelines aren't
crazy they're not specific enough I
don't think we have the testing level to
support starting to do what Donald
Donald Trump is suggesting we need much
much more testing but the guidelines
aren't as crazy as I was thinking Trump
seems to be recognizing that he doesn't
have the authority to tell governor's a
damn thing and someone clearly got to
him and said let's make it clear
governor's can do this on their schedule
rather than on hours that's the right
move very very clearly constitutionally
that that that's the right move I don't
know what's going on in front of the
White House we've got a bunch of
security standing next to some trucks
including a FedEx truck I have no clue
what this is about
I guess banking delivery workers in some
way shape or form I don't know
Anthony Lowe's a go $100 super chat was
talking to someone in the stream okay
Lee Meade asks if the door to the north
is closed Oh Canada yeah no change on
border stuff so far as far as we know
do I think elf ouchy is compromised
I think he's mildly compliment
compromised in the sense that he has
determined it's really important that he
stay on this task force and thus he
can't just go out attacking Trump at
everything he says so I would say that
he is in a sense mildly compromised
mildly compromised Robert well sends a
super chat Ian Howard says I'm having a
hard time getting around the argument
per capita testing is irrelevant to the
u.s. because of our massive population
could you help yes the what is going on
here by the way the answer of course is
this live it this must have been earlier
right this was with FedEx period this
was with FedEx people earlier a lot of
nonsense going on here yeah I got I was
engaged in a crazy that I posted this on
Twitter earlier actually
so Kaylee McKenna nee is the new Trump
press secretary and she got right to the
disinformation tweeting under president
Trump's leadership we have quickly
developed the most expansive and
accurate testing system in the world I
responded we're 39th and testing per
capita looks like you're fitting right
in
some dude
but it sounds like our relatively large
population is beyond your grasp of
course missing that per capita is all
about our large population we are
talking about tests per population that
is exactly what we are talking about
there so dealing with a lot of very
uninformed this is what we call I I know
some people are mad that I'm using the
word weaponized a lot lately when I talk
about weaponized ignorance this is what
we're talking about it is ignorant and
it has been weaponized in a way that
very rapidly spreads exponentially
greater disinformation the virus spreads
virally and the disinformation about the
virus also spreading virally all right
that does it for me today we will be
back tomorrow pending another press
briefing we've got clips we've got all
sorts of stuff make sure that if you're
watching on YouTube before you leave
before you leave smash the like button
and destroy the subscribe button thanks
for joining me I'll be back tomorrow and
later today with clips
you